hi i'm such a fan of you thank you
i'm a fan of yours it's rare though like
i feel like when actors are that
talented where you do you can be funny
you can be serious it's all the emotions
i love all your movies they're so
different it's cool you just got right
to it thank you very much
my daughter called me today who's at our
ranch right now and she said oh my god
you're doing kelly clarkson yeah oh my
god like you're cool oh like you're
really
cool that's like so now i'm cool oh that
was like me wait that was me with my
kids um they're five and seven and
ariana grande they were like you know
her oh yeah and i was like sure okay
i do she's awesome but i'm cultured 3 28
3 one oh my god they're so that's very
far that's kind of cool though yeah but
i got that one thing like on the street
where they're like grandpa and i go no
no no no no really
no i feel like it's so normal now it's
like it is kind of i guess not is it
normal now i don't know i get i don't
know we're in the entertainment industry
so i feel like it's normal ah that's
tough yeah i'm just saying yeah i don't
feel like it's maybe normal like no it's
part of the contract that you signed you
have to have babies after 50.
hey i waited till i was 30 to start
creating and yes and i am glad i did
because i said procreating
i could call it something else if you
want totally it's daytime i was trying
to be like family friendly no but i
waited and i'm glad because i had a life
yeah like i enjoyed my 20s yeah i had my
first when i was 20.
19 when she was pregnant 20 25 50 and
52. and then i'll do 67
i've got i've got a plan
i like a man with a plan it's nice it's
nice um i hope it's okay that i
mentioned the goonies because i here's
the thing it's probably yours since
you've been gone that's the song every
it's the only song people think i've
done in my career i feel like sometimes
and and and i'm like cool there's other
songs and i know there's other movies
there's a plethora of many movies that
you're in that you're amazing but yeah
this was your verse this is the movie
that only means something to you no
no no it's just i think about coming of
age like whenever i was a kid like first
of all i watched this movie with my kids
and i was like holy
you can't watch this with your kids i
forgot how much cursing is in it
i was like
and i was like but yeah i was like ah i
just tried to be louder than like what
was happening but i didn't realize like
what i was watching when i was a kid but
i'm watching you right now like you
watch the goonies you talking about the
goonies is as entertaining for me as you
watching the games i was such a fan of
them and it was who's your favorite
character i'm sorry to interrupt but
who's your favorite character this is
going to get you but we were going to
get married so that's that's why so
no
this is our picture
this is this is like the first time i
met steven tyler and he was like hi it
was like you like it was like yeah we
were gonna get married it's weird we
didn't but um
it was you and steven tyler for me yeah
and i loved it are you gonna have two
husbands is that what you mean well i've
already had one so who knows hey who
knows hey again we got a lot of those
coming up we've got a lot of those
promises
the greatest
38 years of doing movies goonies was the
number one greatest experience and i
went through like 20 years
because goonies was really the only
thing that people knew oh until before i
did no country and grindhouse and then i
kind of my the trajectory of my career
changed a little bit labor day wasn't
yeah but
so people would say the goonies during
that 20 years and you'd kind of cringe
yeah and then now it's a different thing
because you have other movies that you
can resort to when they say the goonies
i love it yeah
because it was like
it was your first experience doing
something like that so that had been
like fun like camp like with everyone i
was like cam because it was the first
movie i ever did you don't do that and i
thought every movie after that was going
to be like that and i was really really
wrong wrong
really wrong because sometimes you
probably get on set and you're like i
don't like these people by the way you
say that most of the time but
by the way so this there's a guy who
follows me on instagram saying brad
tindall and he's like a goonies fanatic
and he's going to hate me saying that
but
i reached out to him oh and he sent me
this which is an original patch um
that we kept on our yeah okay you guys
aren't that impressed i am and i
actually just thought of the actual
jumper that's that i'm going to put it
on okay go ahead there you go
my green one it's going to go here
from the ship this is an original
doubloon chester copperbot
chester compromise i'm telling you i'm
not totally i know you know i am a v you
have no idea so i'm a little let down by
your audience but that's okay um i i
don't worry i'm here
i don't have those i meant to save those
when i was a kid i don't have those so
that came to me and that's for you oh my
god thank you i kid you not i literally
pictured the jumper i'm putting on a
screen good okay and i'm probably gonna
make that into a necklace don't worry
about it i had plans is it true i did
not know this but is it true that you
had like a punk rock career i didn't
know that in the 80s i did i the career
no i had a punk rock band wait what was
your band name the ban i can't say it on
here man why rich kids on lsd why can't
you say that
like
was this like a there's one dude right
over there that's like
yes
like a self-portrait experience
no i started in the garage version of
the band before we had the name and then
i was like quickly fired because i was a
bad i was at oh my god
i love this yeah i'm not in that picture
but i love that too but is this your
this is the band that's the band yeah
that's jason sears and that's chris
wrestling we didn't watch youtube we
were like we wanted the one when they
were popular i'm just kidding
i mean you know how they tell you like
you being a brilliant singer like they
tell you feel it yeah that was us
feeling it
i love that so wait so i want to talk
about your new show so how do you
explain it to people because
it's very different like you feel like
you're watching a western and then all
of a sudden it's kind of supernatural
which i love i like it too i like the
fact that it is a straightforward
western the western the western genre is
very simple straightforward it's us kind
of harkening back or longing to a
simpler time and all that and then you
bring in supernatural elements you bring
in metaphysical elements and you just
turn the whole thing on its head and to
me
the interest is not necessarily in the
supernatural elements but it's bringing
something so
uncontrollable and then you get to watch
the kind of behavioral tweaks that
humans go through when they can't
control something
do you know what i mean and that's kind
of yeah i'm in therapy yeah that's the
same thing so i definitely know what you
mean
um do you believe in the supernatural i
i i don't how can you not like we had
something happen at my house oh where it
was like the moving and it really was it
happened at my house where the thing
moved and three people saw it i didn't
see it oh yeah yeah but i haven't seen
that thing like my kids walking in and
having black circles under their eyes
like with their arms out like that and i
don't want to see that that's when i'd
move i don't that's right that's when i
would go right
you can have this house you believe in
it i do but i've never i feel like
um there's enough
chaos and unrest in this realm that i
don't really need another one you don't
need it yeah and i feel like anything in
that realm knows that i would die
if i saw something just like just
just die yeah yeah no i understand i
would be so scared it would not be a
good experience would you go icy like
that like instant rigorous like like
like those goats oh yeah yeah like the
guns
just i swear to god i didn't i didn't
drink at lunch i just
i did have half a snicker sugar is
amazing you know what you remind me of
and i'm sorry i keep child no child a
little bit but my mother my mother is
from texas you're you're right you you
have personality like yeah from corpus
christi oh my god that's where we all go
that's the place you go for like yeah
yeah yeah yeah
i'm a fort worth girl but whatever
um just for whatever cross your mind
it's a good song um we i sugar does not
do well for me at lunch
[Music]
you